All right. Welcome everyone to the DDPS seminar.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First, please mute yourself during the
talk. But if you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask questions. Or
you'd have to post your questions so that we can
address them in q&a session at the end. Second,
today's GDPR seminar is open to external audience.
Therefore, no classified discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel. Okay,
let me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Yan Christopher,
who is an assistant professor at cardio cardiology
and bioengineering in University of California,
San Francisco, please close by from Livermore
where I am. He also serves as head of cardiac
vision laboratory in UCSF, and then obtained a
PhD in biophysics at University of Goettingen.
In Germany in 2014. He did his a postdoctoral
study at Max Planck Institute for Dynamics
and self organizations from 2014 to 2018, and
served as a staff scientist at Department of
cardio Cardiology in University of Medical Center
going on in Germany, or before he comes to came
to UCSF. He has on NIH new investigator
awards and TP two in 2022. Okay, today,
Yan will talk about predicting heart rhythm
disorders from spatial temporal imaging data
using artificial intelligence. Please
enjoy and expect a wonderful talk. Now,
let me ask a couple of questions. If you don't
mind me, and just to get to know you better and
then make this seminar somewhat informal for first
question is, obviously you are passionate about
hurt or medical field in general, is is there any
moment in your life when you realize that? Wow,
this is it? This is the field I would like to
commit my career to do you have that money?
So the question was, when
was that moment when I want
it? Yeah, yeah. Yeah. And if
you can describe that moment?
Yeah. Yeah, I think, um, one thing that I need to
say and before is that I never wanted to become a
scientist, it was not not a lifelong dream of
mine. When I was younger, I never imagined to
be a professor or scientists later on in my
life. I think I did a PhD out of curiosity,
because I wanted to spend time on on working
on quantitative biology, I think there was
my interest somehow. And then spending six
or seven years, almost eight years on this
one important publication that defined my career
that came out in 2018. In nature, even opened up,
I think the way for me to even consider becoming
a professor. So it was a pretty late decision. So
I was already way into my postdoc and published
an impactful paper and then realized, oh, wow,
I can actually do this. If I want to, I can, I can
try and get a tenure track faculty position and,
and keep doing this for the rest of my life.
Maybe even. And I think before that, I didn't have
necessarily the plan to do that. I see. It was
a thing. At that point, I was definitely hooked.
I was really intrigued by this type of research
that has had built up over the years. And then,
you know, in that moment, it became clear. Okay,
I want to do that. That was roughly in 2018.
Wow. Well, I didn't know at some
point in your presentation today.
Maybe you can share. What was that? Paper? Yeah,
I will have one slide about that
paper. And it's awesome. It is
kind of the foundation for for the last,
the second half of my talk. This paper
I see as well. Okay, the I have one more
question. If you don't mind. Obviously,
you're using artificial intelligence
for your research. When were you first
exposed to artificial intelligence and
decided to use that in your research?
So I think the first time I heard about
Convolutional Neural Networks was in the
cafeteria at Max Planck in 2012. And 13 You know,
when Alex net and all that came out and people
talked about it, but for many more years, I didn't
get my fingers on it. Yeah. It was actually only
during the pandemic, when our Institute's shut
down, when I sat at home. And my student and I,
we both kept talking about how we wanted to
progress and make it or not improve certain
computational methods that we have developed
and talked about auto encoders in unit. And,
you know, I just tried it out and it
worked right away. And it was amazing.
And I will have in my talk, I will have
a few slides about exactly that. Awesome.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you,
and I'll state is yours. Okay,
thank you, Sue, for the invitation and the
introduction. Again, my name is John Kristof.
I work at the Cardiovascular Research Institute.
I'm appointed in the Division of Cardiology here
at UCSF. My background is in physics, I obtained
a PhD in physics. And let me briefly introduce my
lab. And you will notice here that most people
in my lab also have a quantitative background,
either computer science, physics, or electrical
engineering. And the pictures here are kind of
weighted by how many contributions are how
important these lab members are, or were
over the past years. And you can notice here young
labor is a central figure in my lab. He was also a
PhD student and getting an A in Germany and came
down with me to set up the lab here at UCSF. And
a lot of the work that I will talk about today
was actually done by him. Then we were also able
to recruit Trey last year, who has a background in
physics and computer science worked as a software
engineer and he is interested in computer vision.
So he has built important numerical methods for
us. And then on the right side, Daniel, he is
now at Caltech, he was an undergraduate student
who made very important work last year together
with Yun, and on the bottom left here tarnish
who has an interest in you know, everything deep
learning and in particular diffusion modeling and
he he did the diffusion modeling work that I will
also show so, what what can we do as physicists,
mathematicians, or engineers in cardiology, and if
you are interested in this topic a bit further, I
can recommend this podcast that came out recently
in quantum magazine that's that's a really nice
magazine I I often read, and Steven Strogatz,
who's an applied mathematician from Cornell,
he interviewed Flavio Fenn was a colleague of mine
from Georgia Tech, and he spent many years leads
a group there, and they research questions such
as How can we predict what the heart does next?
And how can we intervene and apply defibrillation
pulses in order to stop heart rhythm disorders,
and they talk about that at length. And we do very
similar research with a slightly different focus,
we try to focus on imaging itself. And we
try to understand the interplay between
mechanics and electrophysiology in the heart.
So communities is small, but very persistent
and very active. And very interdisciplinary. We
have, you know, cardiologists, with an interest
in machine learning, we also have a background
in engineering. We have mathematicians, fight
mathematicians, engineers, physicists, and they
all have their different views and approaches.
But we together we meet quite frequently, at least
once a year, this was, for instance, a meeting in
2018, which also I think helped me to make this
decision that I want to stay in academia and that
I want to give it a try to keep pursuing these
these projects. And this this research topics that
I'm currently working on. It was at the PRDP at
Santa Barbara. And I would say that these people
like us who have a quantitative background,
are very small group in this huge arena of
cardiologist and biologists and physiologists
who research heart rhythm disorders or heart
disease in general. And there's roughly an even
distribution between you know, mathematicians,
physicists, engineering computer scientists
how to how to say who dominates this field,
say, last year, we organized a meeting or mini
symposium at Siam conference, and this year again,
we will meet at the same conference. And this
is also something that we we often participate
in or organize. And the people who come there
are regular people who who've done have come to
these meetings since many, many years they keep
showing up. So the heart is an electromechanical
pump. That is something that I need to introduce
first, the most important property of cardiac
muscle cells and you see here one on the left
side is that they are electrically excitable
they are the transmembrane potential undergo was
variations over time that serves that that's a
way of communicating for these cells. And these
changes are referred to as action potentials.
You see there on the right side, three curves. The
first one, the green one is the action potential.
As soon as cardiomyocyte experiences such an
action potential, it opens intracellular storage
for calcium and the calcium is then released
into the cell and the calcium kind of fuels
the contraction of the cell. So the contraction
follows the action potentials is elicited by the
action potential. Then, this electric excitation
overall on the global scale, the heart triggers
and orchestrates the heartbeat, we have in
our heart, multiple centers, the sinoatrial
node and backup node. And in there are cells that
beat autonomously, roughly one time per second,
and then they shoot out electrical excitation
through a cable, and then through through a branch
of other cables into the main heart muscle tissue
that is shown here. And this heart muscle tissue
consists of roughly 5 billion cardiomyocytes. And
once this electrical excitation reaches the end
of these so called purkinje fibers, they exit
at these sites excite the first cardiomyocyte
or small group of cardiomyocytes, and they pass
on this excitation to the neighboring cells. And
so via diffusive process, this excitation then is
propagated through the entire cardiac muscle and
this excitation propagates through the muscle
tissue at a speed of one meter per second. So
it's relatively fast. Then atrial fibrillation
and ventricular fibrillation are the two most
severe forms of heart rhythm disorders. There are
many different flavors of heart rhythm disorders,
but those are the most prominent ones, because
they either affect many, many people or they are
highly deadly, so atrial fibrillation affects the
pre chambers of the heart, the atria, that can be
a chronic condition that you can have for many
weeks or months before you have your elective
procedure to get rid of atrial fibrillation. And
the atrial fibrillation itself is very problematic
because it can cause heart failure or induced
ventricular fibrillation, which then affects the
main chambers and is immediately life threatening,
however, then trigger fibrillation can also occur
on its own. Without atrial fibrillation, it
can occur spontaneously. And you often have,
sadly, these reports here that you can do, I
can update the slide every three, four months,
another celebrity dies from sudden cardiac
death, it is very common, and it affects really,
people at all ages, can sometimes affect people
who do sports, especially in professional sports.
At a very young age, it can affect people with
genetic defects at a young age. But, of course,
it becomes more and more prevalent, the older
you become. Physicists describe these electrical
wave phenomena with partial differential
equations. And we'll have a few slides about
that. And here are some reviews about that and
which nicely summarize the work that has been
done in our field. In short, you can see here an
electrocardiogram at the top and that describes
a sudden onset of ventricular fibrillation, so
the most severe, most deadly form of heart rhythm
disorder. On the left side, you can see the QRS
complex here, which corresponds to a heartbeat,
the C corresponds to the atria contracting
this to the ventricles contracting and GC are
three heartbeats. Before all of a sudden, out of
nowhere, this ventricular fibrillation sets on.
And we associate with this episode here three
computer simulations that describe the spatial
temporal dynamics of the electrical waves that
determine the heartbeat doing these three stages
here. So the normal heart rhythm is caused by a
plane wave that really originates down there with
the Purkinje fibers inject the excitation into the
heart muscle, then this wave propagates upwards,
and needs to be re initiated by the sinus node.
And here are what happens here is that this wave
becomes perturbed and undergoes a transition into
this spiraling or rotating state and we refer to
this wave of form here as a square wave scroll
because it's it's curled up like that. And this
square wave can even further degenerate into
spatial temporal chaos, which is only on the
right side. And these computer simulations
are supposed to illustrate what we think
happens inside of the heart. muscle during these
different stages, we can model cardiac cells in
that sense as relaxation oscillators or nonlinear
oscillators. And you see here an example of a
quite old mathematical model for such a relaxation
oscillator that Fitzhugh Nagumo model and in in
such a model you have two equations one stands
for the excitation one for the refractoriness
and the kind of compete with each other whenever
the excitation goes up the refer to nets also go
excitation and in phase space you then have
this behavior here that most of the time the
cell is in the fixed point, but if you perturb it
slightly if the cell receives excitation from one
of the neighboring cells, then you perturb this
oscillator here over this separatrix and you see
an excursion through face space, which corresponds
over time to an action potential is a mathematical
modeling of of the electrical activity can in
principle be divided in either this synthetic
bottom up approach, where you measure all
ions in cells or ion channels and in their
contribution to these transplant their potential
and an ion fluxes to the cells on analytical top
down or phenomenological approach such as the
Fitzhugh Nagumo approach, where you kind of
mimic the behavior of action potentials using
these relaxation oscillators. And of course,
over the years, this was back then in the 50s.
Many many different models were developed and we
kind of distinguish them into either these ionic,
very detailed models, which are computationally
expensive, or phenomenological models,
which are cheap and, and easy to implement,
but also are less realistic, or any hybrid
version between these two extreme forms.
And this is kind of the sweet spot. For instance,
defendant comma model is one model is used widely
and there are many other models which are, which
consists of fewer equations and fewer parameters,
but sufficiently many parameters so that you
can recapitulate the most important dynamics
of the heart. So, if you didn't connect all
these oscillators in a tissue, you have them
nonlinear waves of electrical excitation,
which propagates through the tissue and here,
this is a cellular automaton. And you see if,
if you excite one cell passes on the excitation
to neighboring cells, and eventually, this wave
dies out at the boundary, because it's followed
by this refractory wave that prevents further re
excitation of the tissue. And this is important,
this is the most important property of our heart
that the excitation is supposed to occur once a
second and that it's also supposed to die out so
that the heart can relax again. The big analogy is
for instance, fire front you have excitable tissue
that is maybe dry grass on the excitation wave
itself is a fire front and the refractory powders
the fuel has has burned and has gone into the fire
can turn around and re excite or re ignite the
forest. Now, in a continuous medium, we can nicely
simulate this with a PDE s. And in this case, this
is a special form of a reaction diffusion system
you can see here again, this is a diffusive term,
these are local reaction, local reaction terms
that describe the excitability of the tissue. So
again, you have a state and a threshold. And once
you perturb this oscillator over the threshold,
you have this excursion the action potential and
then due to the diffusion, you have here this wave
that propagates outwards and then dies out at the
system boundaries. Now cardiologists they try to
measure these wave phenomena in patients, however,
there are many limitations in terms of how
practical it is to access the tissue to measure
and obtain recordings from from patients. The gold
standard currently is to use on so called catheter
mapping. So catheters are inserted into a patient
this procedure is called minimally invasive,
but nevertheless it is invasive. And then under
anesthesia, cardiologist required here electrical
activity from these tips of these catheters now
many different designs and shapes. But what it
is in the at the end of the day, it is a point by
point measurement. And it's a lengthy measurement,
it's time consuming because they have to
reposition the catheter. And you have to
assume that there's reason that this patient is in
a stable as soon as it is irregular and chaotic.
They cannot obtain reliable measurements. So it
is really only applicable in patients that have
a stable, abnormal rhythm. Nevertheless, you can
obtain very nice maps from patients see a patient
that is an A procedure and has been tricky attack
Ikaria you can see here, two maps one was obtained
on the on the epi card, the outside of the heart
and one was obtained on the undercard of the heart
and the inner surface. And these two recordings
were obtained kind of simultaneously and and
were synchronized in time. You see this kind of
rotating wave pattern and this is a wave pattern
that shouldn't be that it is abnormal, and that
causes irregular beats or irregular contractile
function. And it's it's circulating around this
area here where there's presumably a scar in this
patient. So this patient had a myocardial infarct.
And then what can happen is that these waves get
caught there and they kind of circulate around
these infarcts. However, they can also be much,
much more complex rhythms. And you can see here an
excised Picard on the left side that was excised
at the Masters University in the Netherlands.
And they you can see very nicely how chaotic.
This is hard contracts during ventricular
fibrillation. And on the right side here,
this is a rabbit hole that we have imaged
in our lab during ventricular fibrillation
that we induced electrically. Now we'll slow down
this video for now, and I hope it plays smoothly,
you can see now overlaid action potential waves
in pink, which correlate with this mechanical
contraction at the heart exibit trim and trigger
formulations. So here we have a measurement of
these chaotic leaf parents obtained on the
surface. Another example, how fast and how
irregular the contractions can become. And this is
a very extreme example of a technology regulating,
there's almost no contractor activity and more.
This is why venture preparation is so dangerous,
there's no blood flow any longer. So we can
in a laboratory setting excise hearts and keep
them alive for roughly one day. And do imaging
experiments with these hearts, we have fused
them with liquid called tyroid solution, which
is essentially water plus salts plus sugar and
oxygen to keep the pH level at a level where it's
supposed to be. And then we apply something that
is called retrograde perfusion, we pump blood,
this solution yeah retrograding into the heart,
it closes the valves and it goes into the
coronary vessels and perfuses the heart and
therefore can be kept alive for many, many hours.
So this is our imaging setup that we have built
here at UCSF. You can see the centerpieces here
this imaging chamber, inside of the chambers,
this liquid and the intact heart. The heart
can also be seen here in 12. video images,
these images are acquired simultaneously at very
high speeds 500 images per second by these cameras
that are here on this table. And on the left side,
you can see a commercial ultrasound system that
is also integrated into the immune system. And
its ultrasound system records three dimensional
volumetric images of the heart of this place where
you can see here, a rabbit heart beating in our
tank. This is the same rabbit heart and this is
the ultrasound transducer here at the bottom. It's
a 2d matrix array transducer that produces between
25 and 100 volumes per second. Again, this is a
drawing here of of these different camera images,
these cameras, cameras are calibrated. And we were
able to reconstruct the entire surface of the
ventricles with 12 cameras that are synchronized
and calibrated. And then we cross register the
optical reconstructions that we can make with the
cameras with the ultrasound data so that we have
structural imaging data plus functional imaging
data that we acquire optically, because optically
we do not only image the surface of the art, but
we have recent dice and these resin dice are then
excited with this green light on the left side,
you can see here 48 LEDs are also integrated into
this imaging setup. And they illuminate the heart
from all sides evenly and excite fluorescent dye
which then emits a particular wavelength one the
red, and this this initial light and carries
information that we can measure and from which
we can extract action potential waves. And this
year now is one such measurement during the normal
heartbeat sinus rhythm. You can see these are 3d
reconstructions with relatively high resolutions
to heart contracts. And you will also notice if
you watch closely, that there's a slight decrease
in intensity, or in slow this video now Don,
again we have added voltage sensitive fluorescent
dye. And this dye indicates action
potential waves or voltage changes.
I don't know if you can see that on Zoom, you
may or may not see it, I can see it pretty
well on my screen, there's a slight decrease
in I will now amplify this decrease. This is
the routine processing step that we do we extract
the signal by simply amplifying it over time. And
you can see here the action potential wave front
in black saw this activation occurs in multiple
sites in the ventricles due to this Purkinje fiber
system that injects regexes excitation and several
sites. We can also measure them accordingly
mechanical strain, which you can see here is
the area change in red that is a decrease in area
change, and blue is of dilation or increase. So
that we are able to measure this is the result
of many many years of work. This technique is
called optical mapping and it is almost 50 years
old. In the 70s. The first measurements were done
with was voltage sensitive fluorescent dyes
and people demonstrated that it is possible
to measure actual potential waves. And then this
technique really had a had its heydays in the 90s,
where people using a single camera were able to
provide the first measurements of ventricular
fibrillation and these wave phenomena in hearts
and isolated hearts. However, they performed these
measurements with pharmacologically contraction,
inhibited hearts and in the past 10 years, I and
other people have contributed or developed either
with with which it is possible to track the heart
and extract the sickness from beating hearts. And
so there are I would say 99% of all publications
that were done many 1000s of publications were
done with these pharmacologically contraction
inhibited hearts. And since 2016 17, roughly,
there are now more and more publications coming
out where this compound called blebbistatin
is stepped out of the experiment. And we can
now study for the first time, mechanics
and electrics at the same time. And also,
what is kind of rare in our field is that people
use multi camera systems such as our system in
order to reconstruct a 3d surface of the heart. So
right now, as far as I know, this measurement that
I showed to you is the only one of its kind. This
is now a measurement of ventricular fibrillation,
you can see that the heart is moving very
slightly, almost not at all. And you can
appreciate he also these chaotic wave parents
that we can observe now on the across the surface
of the house, they are spiraling they're rotating.
And that now begs the question, what what is this?
What what are these dynamics? What is cardiac
fibrillation? This is a very old question that
has fascinated many people for many, many years.
And in the 60s, chemists, physicists and chemists
who I also worked in gutting and in Germany, came
up with this hypothesis, okay, I know that in the
so called blues of simultaneously you chemical
reaction, I see these spiral waves and these
virus must be related to cardiac fibrillation.
Spyros are ubiquitous in nature. There are many,
many different examples and either biology
or in chemistry. This is an example why I
saw them here in the wild in California. And
there are many, many other examples where you
can observe spiral bass in nature. And these
are our reaction diffusion systems. Turns out,
they have all very similar equations, different
compounds that become depleted or regenerated
and that creates these these patterns. So how can
these rotating parents be created? Or how do they
emerge in the heart in particular, they were very
early experiments roughly 100 years ago, where
somebody cut out a piece of a heart and stimulated
in such a way that they were able to see rotating
waves circulating in this in this ring of cardiac
muscle tissue. And that was for a very long time
than the central hypothesis, there must be the
circuits in the heart that sustain this persistent
activation. But since Valentin Krinsky We also
believe that this happens here in this tissue. So
if you activate cells in such a fashion here that
there's an open end of the wave, that can emerge
in the real heart. Or if you keep this part here
temporarily refractory activate this part and this
following happens. This wave is able to rotate
around its open end and this is a spiral wave and
and the central mechanism in the heart It drives
hardware disorders, tacky arrhythmias. This is a
cardiac cell culture where you can appreciate that
this wave pattern really exists in 2d at least.
And this is a recording made by Flavio Fenland,
you also look at Georgia Tech, they really see
here, the voltage and the calcium rotation of
wave that are stationary and then degenerate
into more complex wave patterns over time. These
wave patterns are surprised surprisingly robust,
they can be sustained and highly an isotropic and
very complex geometries, you can see despite the
in the atria, there's varying fibers and complex
geometry, but this rotating wave can live on such
a substrate. Depending on the parameters, and
depending on your genetic makeup, and so on and
so forth physiological conditions, these waves
can have all sorts of different shapes and as
illustrated here in this three variable model,
depending on these two parameters alone, you
can create various different dynamical regimes of
these waves, then the mechanisms how these waves
can break up is is is manifold, there are many
different mechanisms. But one is for instance,
that these waves can interact with themselves,
this leading edge here crashes into the tail
of its of its own tip arm and then can break up
this wave. And this is also shown here. They are
these breathing instabilities that can last and
further down the road cascade into chaos. This is
another illustration this wave propagates through
tissue that is damaged, the white tissue is as not
supporting this wave that will end it accordingly
it can lead to heterogeneity and breakup. So
heterogeneity in general can promote our revenues.
And now in 3d, it becomes a little bit more
complicated. But even in entirely homogenous media
without any heterogeneity in the substrate, you
can have a route into chaos. You can see here a
scroll wave and the blue line is a filament of the
scroll if that's the center around which this wave
rotates. And due to certain instabilities, these
these filaments can interact with themselves and
break up and then cause such a complex turbulent
wave pattern, which is also the underlying
mechanism for this wave pattern be on the right
side. So now to the part where AI and data driven
modeling can help us to better understand or
diagnose problems and disorders. We have applied
various generic deep learning techniques, such as
unit, for instance, to solve certain problems
in our field. One application, for instance,
is that people are interested in localizing
these regions here around which these waves
spiral or rotate, because you can imagine that
if you would remove this point, then this, the
center here would stop shooting out these waves.
And accordingly, this part of the heart would go
maybe eventually back into silence. So getting
rid of these points of these facing polarities
is a way of liberating art. And therefore,
automatically tracking these points is important
and it was already shown in the late 90s, that
you can automatically identify these points,
you embed this temporal signal using a Hilbert
transform. And then in these resulting face maps,
you can compute the gradient of the face and
whenever you compute a circular integral over
the gradients, around such a face singularity, you
get a discontinuity. And these discontinuities can
then serve as a detection mechanism to track
automatically facing layers through or across
the tissue. However, in practice, it is not easy
to do that, even with high resolution data due
to noise and other artifacts. It is sometimes
you end up with spurious face similarities or
measurements that are simply not robust. So
you can see here in a computer simulation,
this works really nicely. But if you imagine you
work with Kathy data mapping, and you have sparse
measurements, only here on these points or among
these points, then the underlying measurement is
far from the ground rules and accordingly the
trajectories of these facing block points that
can deviate quite significantly here shown
on the right side from from the grassroots.
So we thought this is the perfect problem for
units autoencoder or LSDM version of a unit to
process such data. We trained such a network
here or encoding decoding convolutional neural
network with sequence of video of such data. So
this see on the left side are voltage sensitive
measurements. And then on the right side,
we either target discrete points directly,
or we compute face maps and in this face maps then
face similar points. And we saw that this network
can do this easily with only five snapshots,
five measurements, from the activity, even
sparse measurements can provide you a face map. So
it can successfully cross predict these face maps
from electrical measurements. And they are not far
away from the ground truth. And they can do that
with less than 10% of the spatial information.
And so that showed us immediately how powerful
new networks can be for certain applications in
our field. And you can come compare that previous
success saw measurement with maybe this example
here. Once you've seen this energy on the right
side, it will also be much easier for you to
anticipate what this sparse measurement of that
image might be. And then what the network here
does is it has seen so many examples of these
dynamics that it can easily recover the underlying
dynamics from it. The overall prediction accuracy,
of course, goes down, there's sparser and the more
noisy the data gets. But overall, we would still
be able to identify hear these facing lock
points. And for these rotation of parents,
across the surface of of tissue, we've then
applied it to our optical mapping recordings,
you can see a ventricular fibrillation and a
Picard. And we can train this network either
on this data or on simulation data and then
instantly compute these facing loved ones. If
we were to compute these fashionable points for
from our recordings, we would need a very long,
much, much longer recording, at least maybe one
second was he over here, only a few milliseconds
are sufficient to compute these points. Most
interest, interestingly to us was that we were
able to train it on simulation data as shown on
the left side, and then apply it to experimental
data as shown on the right side. Even though this
data here are these dynamics that are shown here
are three dimensional dynamics. And they are,
what we see here is the surface wave pattern of a
three dimensional wave pattern that evolves within
the heart muscle over here on in contrast to the
simulations that we performed are really only two
these that completely different dynamics kind of,
and of course, these computer models also not
not fitted to this real wave pattern here. But
nevertheless, it's sufficient for the network
to perform relatively well. So you can see here
that if we train on simulation data and apply to
simulation data, we have a very high accuracy.
And we can train on pick data and drive data,
meaning that we used isolated hearts from either
pig or rabbit still get a very high accuracy.
And if we only train on simulation and applied
to pick a rabbits, we still get a decent Angular
accuracy. The next problem that we then tried to
address with the following, we can image currently
with our present eyes, the 3d wave pattern, or the
projection of this wave pattern on the surface of
the heart, but these dyes do not really penetrate.
They do penetrate into the heart muscle, but
the light coming out of that muscle cannot reach
the surface because the hardest to thick, and
therefore we don't really know what's going on
underneath the hard surface. And we do not have
measurements of ventricular fibrillation in 3d,
we have computer simulations, but not real data.
And we tested now in these generic toy models
scenarios, how well, convolutional neural network
would be able to extrapolate the three dimensional
wave pattern from two dimensional surface
measurements, you can see on the left side,
a 3d Scroll wave pattern that shoots out waves
towards the surface on the right side, you see,
whatever we can see on the surface. So we're kind
of pretending this is our experimental setting,
and then trained a neural network to predict
from 2d surface measurements. So this is the
surface layer of this bike peeled off and fed
into the neural network. And we used five time
steps of five of these snapshots. And the target
then was the full 3d parent. And this year is a
reconstruction so you can see that works pretty
well. When we look at it from above you see,
this super superficial layers, they are all
reconstructed pretty well. But then if we zoom
in and look at it in more detail, we see that the
construction accuracy decreases with time. I saw
the surface layers here they are sharp and crisp
and also accurate. But the deeper you go, the more
it fizzles out and becomes less accurate. We use
diffusion models in the same way, training them to
predict either from only the surface top surface
or from the bottom surface or from both surfaces,
the three dimensional wave pattern and saw
that they perform similarly to a simple unit
architecture. However, if you provide them with
more data, they can perform much better than
unit. So we did a mistake kind of we we tried to
reproduce the same results that we obtained with
the unit and with unit we saw that as saturation,
if you provide unit more than five frames, let's
say 10 frames 20 3050, the the network doesn't
become better at it. And we then also stopped
with the diffusion model was five friends because
we thought it didn't get any better with the unit
model. But here, Stan and I were able to show
that if you actually use more data and provide
more data to the diffusion model, and with more
data, I mean, you know, these five samples that we
extracted were five snapshots of one rotation of
such a spy wave, forcing you to take into account
how fast do these waves propagate to the surface,
and so on and so forth. And here, if you have
much, much more data that goes maybe beyond one
period of the spiral wave, then you can actually
decrease this error quite a bit. Nevertheless, you
can see that the deeper you go, the greater the
uncertainty and Arabic columns. And therefore
this is maybe not the best approach to try to
extrapolate these complicated chaotic dynamics
from surface observations alone. And therefore,
another approach is needed. And this is something
that I would discuss now in the second part of the
talk. Before I jump into that, I wanted to mention
that I told him he in 1903 came up with this
invention of the electrocardiogram and since then,
the electrocardiogram has had tremendous success
in cardiology, everyone uses it, it's very cheap,
it's very effective. And you can immediately even
at home yourself can assess the state of your
heart, you can say, okay, my heart is beating
normally or all something is something is wrong,
I need to see a doctor. And it's very cheap. So
therefore, I think people have never really dare
to come up with alternatives to this. The problem
was the electrocardiogram and all electrical
measurements is what I just showed to you, you can
not access the entire heart, and you cannot really
visualize what's going on beneath the surface of
the heart. And this focus on the electrocardiogram
has maybe kind of blended us and prevented us
from from looking at what's already there, and the
heart beats the heart contracts, and it's visible,
you can use an ultrasound machine, we can use MRI,
and we see the contractions of the heart, and we
can analyze them. And so therefore, we could
now ask the question, can we actually calculate
the electrophysiology or the action potential wave
parents that trigger the contractions of the heart
from the motion of that, and this is, you know,
illustrated in these three idealized ventricular,
by ventricular electromechanical simulations,
you can see on the left side, this plane wave
here induces a very distinct, contractile pattern
that is distinct from the contractor pattern that
is induced by to rotating waves or by five or
more rotating waves. So it should be possible
to compute something like that. But we didn't have
the measurement data that could actually give us
this this certainty or this experimental evidence
that would support this hypothesis. And here,
in our setup, we have no such data that motivates
this even further, you can see here, this wave
that propagates across the ventricles of a rabid
heart, and this weight induces a contraction that
is highly correlated with the action potential
where it's not that everything contracts at once.
It is really that the contractor activity sets on
and and follows the action potential. And then the
two questions that we had initially and we still
have, and I'm trying to address this, is this
sufficient information to compute electrical
activation, if you looked at this mesh here,
is that enough? And is this mapping
between electronics and mechanics unique?
These three images here show you how closely
correlated that actually is the action potential
wave here propagating from the left to the right.
And users contractor activity over there, because
the contracts over there which was shown here and
the strain rate in which tissue is being pulled
towards the wave, and that tissue dilates as a
concept plants and this is a very characteristic
phenomenon that we observe over and over now
in our experiments. And this weight frontier
between dilating strain and contractile strain is
following the action potential wavefront. There's
a small delay that is typical for cardiac tissue
and it propagates in the same direction. So,
there is really experimental evidence that
justifies this approach. And there are more
observations that we made in the past. So here
you can see waves with your this is a recording
that we made with the phone, mechanical waves
propagate through the heart of the solid was
treated with cardioplegic solution. And therefore,
the activity was pretty slow down and what you
can see the space this now is the paper that
I mentioned in the beginning, I studied this
mechanical deformation pattern in the ventricular
was in computer simulations and then also made
recordings measuring hear voltage calcium and
strain and you see here a clockwise rotating
pattern and all of these three quantities. So down
here, we I was able to compute phase singularities
that indicate the rotational centers of these
waves for voltage, calcium and strain. And there
are there are we published in two papers that
one is a physics based approach one is a deep
learning based approach in which we try to compute
now electrical waves from mechanical deformation.
And I will briefly talk about this year, mainly
because I wanted to highlight how much better deep
learning works actually. So the first approach is
a data simulation approach. We say system one is
the system that we want to measure. System two is
a virtual replication of that system, we introduce
sensors in the system that we want to measure and
controllers in the virtual replication of that
system and drive the system with the measurement
data that we have available eventually from system
one. So we can see here to come excitable media
excitable systems, system one exists system two,
and there's a coupling term here and this coupling
term is really only difference between the states
of these oscillators over here versus here. And
because we do sometimes explain that much better
than 1000 words, you can see that here, this
computer simulation is coupled to the psychiatry
measurement over here. And just constantly
receiving input from this from these sensors
over here by by the controllers that are placed in
this domain. And you see that this simulation code
evolves with the cyclotron. And we adapted this
principle and and modified it a little bit. We
have we know that based on our measurements, these
electrical waves and use also mechanical waves,
therefore it might be possible to do exactly
this, slightly modified instead of having in
your control term, a comparison between the
two electrical states, you can now compare
either an electrical and mechanical state or the
mechanical state of system one, the mechanical
state of system two, and modify the electrics in
such a way that the mechanics of the second system
match the mechanics of the first system. So that's
shown here we have sensors in our drive system
are the first system that we want to measure
which measure mechanics strain, for instance,
strain rate, and they modulate the controllers
and the electrics of the second system. So here
we have a spiral wave that induces mechanical
contractions, red is contraction, glues dilation,
we added some noise to it and then observed
that and induced electrical excitation in these
locations here, wherever contraction occurred
was a negative electromechanical delay. And
you can see that over time, this system becomes
synchronized with the first system and therefore
we have a reconstruction of the dynamics in the
first system based on a mechanical measurement.
And then we were relatively happy that this also
works for very complex wave parents. So you can
see here comparison of the reconstructed wave
pattern from mechanics with the original wave
parent to apology is very similar. However,
there were quite significant differences too.
So we were happy about an 80% reconstruction
accuracy. But all of that was kind of killed
with deep learning because it worked right away
much better using simply an autoencoder for this
problem. So we trained an autoencoder and a unit
with pairs of mechanical deformation patterns
with electrical excitation patterns that cause
six deformation patterns. You see a spiral wave
pattern that induces together with multifiber
anisotropy this anisotropic spiral wave like
mechanical deformation pattern, the Folker wave
pattern, a more complex wave pattern and we use
20,000 samples of such pairs to then estimate
to electrical waves from mechanics with unseen
data. So the network architecture again was a
simple encoder decoder, we analyze displacements,
x and y displacements in 2d which could either be
with ref with respect to an undeformed, mechanical
state or any arbitrary mechanical state, or
the previous mechanical state of the system,
and saw that this works pretty well, after a
short period of training. And after a few epochs,
this is an example of 3d dynamics, very, very
turbulent dynamics. These dynamics induce tiny
mechanical deformations here, which were analyzed
by the network. And this is the reconstruction.
It's visually indistinguishable from the original
dynamics. So, the complexity of the wave parents
really no limitation. And you can see here on the
right side, those are wattics filaments that were
computed either from the original wave parent or
from the reconstructed wave parents in black and
gray and perfectly overlap. So now the question
is, how is this applicable in patients can we use
this to reconstruct electrical activity in
a patient who is there in in the clinic and
doing such a procedure here you can see, this
heart is beating abnormally, this patient has
ventricular tachycardia. And at the center is
the tip of a catheter. So this person performs
this procedure here of mapping the patient, and
spends many, many minutes maybe a full hour to
obtain a 2d map of the electrical activity. But
since we are measuring this at the same time,
this ultrasound recording, we could instantly
provide this activation map if we are able to
compute it from the mechanics. So we perform
computer simulations, again, idealized by our
trickier computer simulations, which retain
muscle fiber architecture that is necessary in
electromechanical simulations. This massive fiber
architecture determines how the heart contracts,
but also how the waves propagate. Then one issue
was that we needed roughly at least 10,000,
or maybe ideally 50,000 training samples. How do
you get that many training samples and computer
simulations that are usually traditionally very
expensive. So we use sphinxes, which is smooth
particle hydrodynamics. framework, because it
provided us sufficient speeds, and we were able to
compute one episode here in less than 10 minutes
and could therefore over the course of a few days,
simulate enough training samples. And then this
problem becomes the following. Here we have three
dimensional point cloud of three dimensional
motion vectors, which describe the movement,
the formation of the ventricles, the target is
a static voltage wave pattern. Again, we have
many many different examples of these pairs, and
the unit that we then use as a sparse res unit,
we use this Minkowski engine here to process
unstructured grid data and convert it into a
format that this unit understands. The inputs
are five frames, describing five states of the
mechanical information state of the heart,
that could in principle be extracted from
ultrasound recordings, MRI recordings, and the
target is then the electrical morphology of the
wave pattern. In the computer simulations,
we varied for different electrical models,
which are produced very distinct electrical
wave parents with four constitutive laws
for the mechanics. And then randomized initial
conditions model parameters, the geometries of
the tissues can either induce focal or reentrant
base, you can see here, the different anatomical
geometries that also have an influence on the
fiber architecture, and created 1000 different
geometries, plus five architectures and then
varied our initial conditions. So we for instance,
stimulated the heart at the bottom at the front
or the back in random positions, or induce
these different spiraling wave parents also in
random positions. And you can see here how these
different electrical models produce very different
qualitatively different way quantitatively
different wave patterns. Again, this these are
four examples. This is maybe a more realistic
simulation that would be more comparable to
what's what's happening in a patient who has
a BT episode, and this is a more idealized
computer simulation. We also in space,
vary the model parameters accounting for spatial
heterogeneity, and overall varied randomized More
than 15 I think parameters and also included
scar tissue or heterogeneity. So here in red,
these parts of the tissue did not contract or did
not conduct. And then we were happy to see that
this works, we can actually train such a network.
This is the ground truth electrical wave pattern
that induced this mechanical deformation pattern,
they are shown on the left, this was the input
to the network. And this is the prediction that
works for focal wave patterns, we can compute now,
these activation maps here from these a sequence
of predictions of electrical wave patterns. This
is an activation map that was directly computed
from the sequence of electrical snapshots. And
then from this mechanical deformation computer,
this sequence down here and this activation map,
and it's very similar. And you can now compute
from the mechanical information of the heart
these electrical activation maps, which are
important for cardiologist because sometimes
they're interested in where in these ectopic beats
these additional undesired beats come from. It
works for reentrant wave activity, also pretty
well. And these are the different accuracies
that we achieved, how much more time do I have?
Do I need to run through the remaining slides?
Or how many how many more? Slides?
11? No. And I might run out of time.
Yeah, maybe you can wrap up. Okay.
I'd like to write a write up next.
Five minutes. next five minutes. Yeah. Okay,
good. So this is an example where the heart
includes also scar tissue. And the prediction
nevertheless, works quite well. This is very
important, because most patients actually do have
myocardial infarct and accordingly, heterogeneity,
and scars. And if this method wouldn't work in the
presence of scars, and it would be useless,
probably. So now, how do we translate that to
the clinic, we showed in computer simulations
that this works, but that can also doesn't
mean that it needs to work with patients, we
have tried to apply the network that was only
trained on simulation data on such data on the
right side, and that obviously did not work. And
our approach now is to generate training data
in our experimental setup with isolated parts,
and then see how well that could perform maybe on
the patient data or fine tune model subsequently,
further down the road with with all of
these different types of data. So this
is the experimental data that we have is really
high quality, electromechanical data of parts,
we know us stimulate the hearts in such a way
that we have many, many different stimulation
sites and the corresponding mechanical
deformation pattern. This is just the
optical recording the red vectors indicating
mechanical information, but we also have,
of course, transmitter with mechanical data
from the ultrasound. And this is shown here,
this is raw ultrasound data segmentation that
deforms based on the 3d motion tracking where we
perform, there's a corresponding target than
on the surface, at least of the electrical
activity. And we are currently in the process
of fully automating these these experiments,
in order to be able to generate 50,000 training
samples, or many, many 1000s of training samples.
So that means that we need to be able to go
into these recordings, pick certain frame
and extract the frames, reconstruct it in 3d,
cross the interest of these two recordings,
and extract here the corresponding data and fuse
the data together. We've seen in other examples
that in terms of generalization, we can train
the sorry, we can train the model and simulation
domain well, and leave out one of the electrical
models and it still works pretty well. We've
applied it to significantly different geometries.
It also works in those we have borrowed data from
from collaborators who use finite element modeling
instead of SPH modeling that we use to train
the model and it also works efficiently when I
think that if we improve our of our methodology,
it should be possible to reconstruct overall
excitation waves from mechanical deformation. Now,
the big question is, how do we get that to work in
our ex vivo imaging setup? And let me jump through
the nebulous slides here we showed that for
instance, in these two dimensional cell cultures,
we can apply a model that was trained only on
simulation data on these experimental measurements
and get we constructions that make us hopeful
that this could actually work in practice. As an
outlook, of course, we would like to use this data
not only for predicting one thing from another,
but also maybe to evolve and obtain a data
driven model of of the heart based on these dis
experimental data that we're able to generate
now in our setup. So we've used the fusion
modeling and saw that fusion modeling can be used
to evolve project dynamics, we can generate shapes
and waves that look like ventricles and reentrant
circuits. And I'm sure that we will also be able
to generate beating hearts, maybe even driven
by the data that we have now in our experimental
setup. So that adds now a third pillar to our
set of tools that we have the conventional
computer simulations. And now maybe, hopefully
soon, also, data driven modeling of curricula
for mechanics. So and I hope I didn't exceed too
much. Thank you very much for your attention. Very
nice. Very nice. Thank you so much for
the interesting talk. Ian. enjoyed it a
lot. Let's have a q&a sessions. So Well, I
first want to introduce you to rob Robert
Blake at Lawrence Livermore. Rob, are you
still there? Yeah, I'm still here. Oh,
cool. So Rob has been working on the
computational model for cardiovascular
system. We have some computational
tools. Rob, do you want to introduce?
Yeah. Hi, Yan. I worked with Natalia for a long,
long time and wrote. So we have cardioid here that
can do a whole bunch of cardiac simulation stuff
you might be interested in. I also have melody
that lets you take anything off cell ml, and
quickly generate code for it to run in chased
or whatever simulator you want. And I have a
really cool data set that you'll want to get
access to. We did a whole bunch of simulations of
just tricky colors, and then recorded pseudo ECGs.
And that was able to train a neural network to
go from the ECG to transmural maps on the Hga 16.
Nice. Okay, yeah, we should definitely talk. Yeah.
Awesome. All right. Let's have a q&a
sessions. If you have any questions, yeah,
please don't hesitate, just unmute yourself
and ask questions. I can I can start. So,
you know, you said that the measurement
can be only done on the on the surface,
right. And in order to fill the gap, you relying
on the computational model, but every patient has
a different shape of the heart? Probably. How do
you deal with that? I mean, it's building those
computational model. One of them will take
some time. And if you have a patient with a
different shape of the part, do you quickly do
you parameterize, the heart computation model,
so that quickly change the shape of the
heart and run the run the heart model?
Good question, I think I don't know. I would
assume that from imaging data would have the
shape of the heart. And the question would
also be How sensitive is the solution to the
shape of the patient? Is it possible to use a
generic shape that represents most patients,
so that adapts slightly to the
imaging data? I'm not sure how,
how the anatomy would influence
potential solutions, those
imaging data is going to give
you the shape of the internal
structure of the heart as well for each patient.
Yeah, yeah, sure. We don't have MRI data or
generally have MRI data or ultrasound data.
Even though ultrasound has a pretty low spatial
resolution, it's possible to to extract at least
the global shape of the ventricles from it with
the Atreides it's a bit more tricky, but that's
definitely possible you wouldn't be able to
extract you know, final structures is especially
on the endo card. And it's also sometimes
not easy to delineate the organ boundaries,
but overall, we can definitely see differences in
in adult anatomy across patients and ultrasound.
One of the techniques you you showed was, you
know, only the using the sun Stata. And well,
I mean, of course, do you use the computation,
3d computational model and then generate the
data and train the unit, for example. And then
once the unit is trained, you just, you know,
get the measurement in sparse way, you had a
particular shape of the measurements and the
location in the space on the surface.
One was the uniform is distributed,
and the other one was the sun. How should I say,
you know, the straight line to the center? Yeah,
I think you mean the Kathina mapping data, right,
that lets us there was a study that couldn't
go back. Yeah, if you can go back. See.
This slide. Basically, my question is,
how how do you? Right? Like that sucks
about last zoom in this the star shape
at the bottom right? The right one?
Yeah, exactly. How do you choose that
location is it's somewhat flexible to
choose those locations. So all of the measurements
in this is completely determined by the
manufacturer of that catheter. So this study
here, by by Ronnie at eye, she there I think,
either chose generic representations of wood,
like this geometers are similar to these
catheters, or they are directly somehow
created from the classical, I don't know. But
there are either these Penta re catheters,
or these lots of catheters, and then also basket
catheters, or just different types of catheters
that are on the market. Some of them have up to
64 I think electrodes, the basket catheters, not
all of them measure something at the same time,
but they can sense which ones contribute to the
measurement. And there are often many different
episodes that that recorded the same time. So
that's where it comes from. And in our study, we
just used something that looks like a star. Got
it? And I think in another
point of your presentation,
you talked about the training the unit,
and then use the training unit to you know,
get the information about the
insight, not just the surface,
I mean, the measurement, the standards on
the surface, but also the internal. Yeah,
yeah, this year. Yeah. Right. So this is, we
pretend that this is a piece of the ventricular
wall. It's, of course, heavily over simplified.
But we were simply interested is from our from a
dynamic systems perspective, is it possible to
reconstruct very chaotic wave parents in 3d in
3d from only surface measurements, which is
a situation which we have in our lab, we can
currently really only measure the outer surface
eppicard. But in principle, you can also measure
from the inside the undercard at the same time.
So you have two cameras, for instance, facing each
other and in between is the hard wall. And in that
scenario, you have two measurements, like here on
the slide. And then whatever happens within the
hardball, the question was, can we recover that
from only these two surface measurements?
On what we what we've learned in these two
studies here Standard Oil and and labor the die
from 2020 we it is possible to some extent, in
this scenario like a one step your network
the neural network is trained after that
is trained for the inference stage,
do you assume that the whole surface
image is available as an input or only the
sparse data on the surface is available?
Here we assume that the entire services
available because the scenario that we
tried to recapitulate was optical mapping. So
optical measurement, we added some noise to it
and saw it also works with noise, no problem,
but we didn't try out a sparse measurement.
So that would be the next step to move to
more realistic geometries and add sparsity
Okay, great. I mean, we have some technology
of you know, you know, enabling that actually,
you know, once you train the like auto
encoder or you net and then only we get
the sparse data on the surface and then try to
reconstruct the whole 3d No output data. Maybe
I can introduce to you after the talk. Yeah,
okay. Well, that's my question. I don't want
to take whole time of the q&a sessions.
Is there any questions from audience
over billion questions, but it'll go weeds.
Only one or two allowed?
How much? How much luck have you had with face
singularities? Every time I've tried to track face
singularities in cardiac tissue? Like, it's super
messy? To do? Absolutely. Yeah, we just gave up
and started with like, just tracking wave fronts
and measuring them as like a 40 surface instead.
Yeah. But yeah, like, under so much. And depending
on like, little tiny things are very sensitive to
air, and they kind of go whoo, wobbly all over
the place, and then disappear and reappear,
like continuity and fade singularity
has always been really difficult for us.
Yeah, absolutely. I agree. So there might
protect ourselves that influenced that.
So the noise and motion artifacts and optical
recordings, at least they can cause, you know,
Basinger's to jump or disappear or something, you
have spurious very similar results are not mere,
that are just a result of the filtering. So we, we
have a protocol, I can send it to you if you want,
that works relatively well when the signal
quality is good enough. So you can process video
data in a way that you focus on the wavefront,
rather than the wave itself. Both way works,
and you have to slightly smooth the data. And
then you remove outliers, from the normalized
data. So what you want to do is you want to
normalize each time series, to amplify the waves,
and then use the Hilbert transform or whatever you
need in order to embed the signal and compute the
face map from it. And then what is very important
is to smooth the face maps using a complex filter.
So you convert the face maps into a 2d vector
field with with a normalized amplitudes. Like
a complex number, and then filter that. And
with that technique we had, were quite like,
it's pretty robust. Of course, it doesn't prevent
you from detecting face singularities that are,
you know, further down further upstream
in the processing pipeline created there,
or just simply the fact that you're looking at a
projection of a 3d wave pattern. And these some
of these spirals and meander really strongly they
they have a linear core rather than a point around
which they rotate. And that can also cause issues.
And there's some work by a group in Belgium that
came out recently where they look at that in
more detail. But it can get very messy. Yes.
Have you ever seen an arrhythmia without a face
singularity? Either linear core or point core?
I know data from Flavio Fenton where he has shown
that I think, have I seen that in my experiments?
I don't think so. Okay, because we I've been we've
been like we saw it all the time and stimulation,
it would happen, especially around scar
structures. And like, the whole face
singularity stuff just really kind of broke down
because we're like, can't find and we have to
do integrals. And we're like half the heart.
We can't find the in the face singularities.
Yeah, the linear core is really an issue. And
that has also raised concerns with this concept
of facing law even makes sense. So the people in
Belgium, Hans Dirks, and his people, they publish
something last year thing where they expand this
concept of a face singularity into different
lines. And it gets also really complicated
highlighting that it is a complicated topic,
more complicated than at least just points
looking at points. I think it's, it's a nice
concept too, too, too, to look at, but I would not
overemphasize it. To describe fibrillation, it's
in the end, it was supposed to reduce complexity,
if you look at a three dimensional wave pattern
that changes quickly in time. So for the wave
pattern, it can become very, you lose track of it.
It's just complicated and difficult to understand.
And therefore I thought back then and 2000s,
it was thought to help people to understand what's
going on and that way it helps because you can
count the number of waves you can determine the
density of these waves. You can see how waves
interact with each other these filaments when they
touch each other and break up. That's that's a
nice concept. But other than that, it's I think we
also need other to was to look at corroboration.
When I see that you you're using
unit or autoencoder type of approach,
that is nice because it gives you some
reduced latent space dimensions and,
you know, bring the data size effectively
reduced to the smaller dimensions and but
have you tried to actually interpret that
any physical meaning on that latent space,
the reduced dimension later in the middle of the
unit or the middle spacing in the auto encoder?
Do you mean if you've ever used visualization
tools of what's going on in the latent space or
physical? Yeah, physical principle later, I mean,
your underlying physics, they say electrical
mechanical systems themselves, you know, I saw you
present his some partial differential equations
associated with it. And, you know, of course,
the data is, you know, if you use the simulation,
that data will be really high dimensional.
So after the auto encoder, it is reduced,
and it's, it's quite unknown, what physical
meaning those latent space has. Maybe you can
put some meaning to it, physical meaning
to it, associated with those electrical,
mechanical, electric, electric mechanical
system. You have? Have you tried that? No,
we, that we we try to kind of verbally, you know,
talk about what what, what happens in the latent
space, maybe here, in particular with these
facing polarities, which is a simple, I think,
a much simpler problem where you only have a
scalar valued field that you transform into a
complex field. You have these two numbers that
define the phase angle? They are, I would say,
the latent space, what is it?
It's that conversion, you know,
that you do with the hero transform somehow,
locally, this is much more local, I think,
in the case of the electromechanics, you have long
reaching elastic effects. So, global motion of I
don't know how it translates different modes of
the contraction of the of the deformation of the
heart that are in the latent space somewhere. I
mean, it's pretty amazing when you look at these
simulations here that you can convert something
like this vector field on the left into a scalar,
varied, filled with complicated geometry,
relatively complicated geometry. It's amazing and
very interesting. Very interesting.
Yeah. What happens to us?
Right? Well, you know, our group, we tried to,
there's a framework we developed called elastic
latent space dynamics, identification, meaning
that so once once you project those 3d motions,
vector field into the latent space through the
auto encoder, and you get some dynamic signal
in the middle of latent space, and we don't
know, what's the governing equations for that
trajectory data, so we try to associate that
with a some sort of differential equations,
and then try to understand what that differential
equations, what kind of meaning it has. So yeah,
maybe I can introduce that to you as
well. Okay, so I have a to do list.
Sounds great. Yeah. I would
love to talk about that.
Awesome. Awesome. All right. Any
other questions from audience?
Well, it's now let's, let's thank
our speaker yarn for the wonderful
talk and interesting talk. I learned
a lot and hopefully we can, you know,
further stimuli stimulator. The collaboration
between Lawrence Livermore and UCSF. Yeah,
would be great. I was very happy when
I found out about this seminar. So it
was recommended to me by Michael Gregory.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks. All right.
Transcribed by https://otter.ai